okay guys okay it's like a bat we're
playing Karen call to tampico and we're
looking for Dean the tampico dieter okay
and see boy kanya right here I'm
basically a lot of people I've been
asking me like yeah like where the [ __ ]
have you been like you know I've been
trying really [ __ ] hard to [ __ ]
like watching videos but you're [ __ ]
missing well let me tell you something I
had somewhat of an incident okay oh [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] is that I basically like
people kept trying to ask my day and up
hmm let's see here
[ __ ] is that
it's like going up and down for it now
anyhow wait does it want to how to [ __ ]
me get back there we go you've got one
of the floors we established good
accessing the users archives now two
more to go oh it seems the casino has
honored guests the villa in happiness
was pounding at the doors now they found
a way inside daily them and don't try
and leave yourself or I'll let the call
of which work Jesus ok I got anything
where's ok um except uh all right cancel
I'm trying to get one of these guys
okay yeah there we go there's a [ __ ]
hallway over there yeah [ __ ] see a
[ __ ] [ __ ] over there I'm tricking
some my smoothie right now you have his
good is it I service I have to like poor
my mouth he got the flow um but yeah so
I got poor my mouth sucks like it sucks
don't if you get the flu again you vile
alive correct I thought flag Terry's
Bobby van thank you got let me hack this
[ __ ] oh god I am just a master hacker
what's the Clinton's emails
hmm
hmm
okay race the time I got cash sometimes
I take that paper cash in this game like
pre-world War money it's just to pretend
that I have money that your real life
yeah I already hacked it that's cool ah
shucks how can I hey yeah that's a good
chef that is some good [ __ ] was still
alive correct that I'll break him where
is where's that [ __ ]
okay okay
okay save a quick saving now where is
that jay says I'm shaking I gonna other
way okay right there's a lot of [ __ ]
things here okay seems I'll a one way
forward so let's do this
ok
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] note that ah yo my
peepees there ok well at least I know
when I go quickly search this ok o
whiskey how can I help take this [ __ ] is
that pack of cigarettes take this wine
take this is odd cut you know pretty cut
up this stuff right I need to check this
for key
now shut
Dorsey aura must be a key for backstage
I'm for it hard for it i'm trying to
[ __ ] out for it
that s like a [ __ ] middle room I can
finally a friendly hey partner up here
the in a bit of a predicament here had
to duck backstage take a powder the
audience as a little I was already
halfway off the rooftop through the
service and before Villa finish to a
gala speech I knew when it happened with
also meant the front gate was open and
no way was I missing it after all these
e no idea what I was back at the fronds
then suddenly Holograms walked out of
the wings this look those ghosts are
going to come out of the wings behind
and if you got in here the doors
probably locked tight behind trust me as
soon as you can run to the door to the
left used as bad as things are is a
right let's see it's most likely filled
with toxins from the vents so hug the
wall make as much space between past
that is my dressing room under the table
there's of not much help against the
ghost still if you're about to give up
all right yah yah right so let's guess
we need to stop and simply I thing is
when the recording cued up a nice calm
appreciative audience appeared in the
theater so find the music get it to the
projector all room up step the holotype
should be where I left it no wait it's
it's anyway snag the key out of my room
and look around vieras room what good
okay [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i thought i
had a cake
okay what the [ __ ] is going on here
what what the [ __ ]
that sucks finally a friendly dick since
it has to go here why is it working why
is that why I came yeah yeah yeah
the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
finally a friend didn't come on [ __ ]
okay okay yes yes yes finally a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yep making a [ __ ] run for it baby
baby baby baby yeah yeah yeah yeah baby
hey Ted not [ __ ] what where's the
[ __ ] her jaw suck and great that's
cool outfit that look at it for you
badass all right I saw that [ __ ] okay
at the risk a rattle cosmic night
that's like that thank you very much
yeah I read drink some of that thank you
okay that didn't he say like there's a
cup there it is Rotech fast thank ya
where is that shoes without a close one
okay okay now no in that up
what everyone has gone on here no what's
in here you know like I thought I need
answers I need answers i an't now thank
you
and they were not Kenny when is it stay
away from those things maybe I can shut
down nice ghosts using the stage
managers over to it damn it so much for
that idea
mmm-hmm this isn't her dresser is it
okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's not doing it where's the other
radium no one [ __ ] now how's baby
yeah I messed up there I messed up bad
what is armor anyhow I take this no no I
cannot
ok ok ok
hey you're making real thrill dress good
look that's theaters room so careful
what you touch be respect meeting babe
oh ok yeah sex a slick way do I have I
love baby
other something like pretty important it
up there it is
ok
what happened here that's a baby scale
that sucked up
cow
[ __ ]
let's tear this
well
presentable for such as you meets an old
a moveable object like me sounds gotta
give surface gotta give something's
gotta give
now deal with the goal this has gone on
long enough oh those electric ghosts
aren't the kind of audience I like at
the best of times don't even know how i
ended up here look I'm more about the
short goodbyes I know you didn't do it
out of the goodness of your heart so but
I'm not an idiot and you're wearing a
collar so i think is here's where being
my part there's a private elevator
Sinclair's elevator veera she was my
other partner before Sinclair was
already puppy and he built this whole
place for her me except Sinclair didn't
know all she had to do was get inside
the Sierra mod would have been the
biggest site the bomb there got sealed
in here a few hundred years ago now we
finished the job Rob the Sierra
problem all high and mighty never got
mad always kept looking for do to me hey
I didn't know at first in the old man
shoot the one who makes all the hand
signs little I put her in the clinic
tuned her like an instrument if that is
so here's the short piece to get a
little miss